[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis ravi de me
retrouver dans les matins du sénat
l'émission qui décrypte avec vous les
travaux des sénateurs avec l'élection du
nouveau président joe biden les
etats-unis ont-ils renouer avec leur
diplomatie traditionnelle à laquelle
donald trump avait mis un coup d'arrêt
c'est à cette question que les
intervenants de cette table ronde
organisée le 31 mars dernier par la
commission des affaires étrangères du
sénat ont répondu relations des états
unis avec l'union européenne mais aussi
avec la russie ou encore la chine
laurence nardon de l'institut français
des relations internationales et
corentin celle un professeur agrégé
d'histoire et spécialiste des états unis
ont livré leur analyse aux sénateurs sur
tous ces sujets diplomatiquement très
sensible je vous propose qu'on regarde
tout de suite cette table ronde et je
vous retrouve juste après pour ma part
je vais essayer donc de dresser un
tableau de ce qu'on peut comprendre de
la politique étrangère de
l'administration baydan sur ces deux
mois
nous sommes le 31 mars donc janvier
février un peu plus de deux mois de de
pratique
alors comme vous l'avez dit dans votre
introduction il ya rupture et continuité
dans cette danse est politique telle
qu'on la voit aujourd'hui mais ce qui
est intéressant c'est que il ya des
ruptures et des continuités à la fois
par rapport à ce que trump a fait dans
les quatre dernières années mais aussi
par rapport à la pratique d'obama et
quand je parle de la pratique d'obama je
veux peut-être aussi par les plus
largement de la pratique traditionnelle
des de la diplomatie américaine
même si la question de savoir si obama
est un président qui pratiquer une
diplomatie traditionnelle il ya des
thèses qui s'écrivent dessus en ce
moment donc on va pas rentrer là dedans
mais en gros il ya dans un premier temps
on va peut-être appeler ça le verre à
moitié plein un retour de
l'adminstration baydan très affirmée à
la diplomatie traditionnelle celle que
les critiques aux etats-unis appellent
de blob le blog c'est une manière un peu
péjorative de désigner
stable hischmann qui fait la politique
étrangère sur la côte est des états unis
des gens très bien élevés très propre
sur eux qu'ils défendent toujours une
vision idéaliste des états unis qui sont
volontiers interventionniste mais pas
toujours complètement enfin vous voyez
les gens qu'on voit aujourd'hui revenir
dans l'administration à la maison
blanche et dans les services du
département d'état là dessus je vous
renvoie un très bon article car écrit
très récemment
notre collègue à corentin et moi c'est
lié à blanc une chercheuse française qui
est à la brookings et qui a écrit un
long papier dans je crois que c'était
l'institut montaigne je suis plus très
sûr jean jaurès hockey fondation jean
jaurès et dans lequel elle décrit
justement elle liste les gens qui
arrivent les diplomates ou les experts
qui arrivent dans les rangs de
l'administration plus de 4000 en tout
ils sont pas encore tout cela bien
entendu c'est un mouvement qui est en
cours et dans lesquels on reconnaît
énormément de noms de personnes qui
étaient déjà là sous obama et peut-être
même avant ce clinton et qui donc sont
des partisans de cette diplomatie
américaine traditionnelle très très
multilatéraliste parce que là je viens
de prononcer le mot important qui est
celui de multilatéralisme
trump honnissait cette pratique qu'est
ce que j'ai dit oui absolument
non non je reprends mes idées
oui donc trump avait absolument owni
cette pratique les institutions
internationales le droit international
tout cela n'avait pas de deux
de légitimité à ses yeux mais évidemment
avec baden on a vu que c'était un retour
affirmé donc on l'a vu sur le climat dès
le premier jour mais on le voit aussi
sur l'otan qui est très important pour
nous mais aussi sur l'union européenne
puisque trump nationaliste détestait le
le projet européen par essence un projet
supranationale pour lui c'était c'était
épouvantable mais là il ya en tout cas
dans le symbole une grande amitié pour
ces institutions européennes et
transatlantiques on l'a vu la semaine
dernière
heiden ar participer à ce sommet de
l'union européenne jeudi soir donc
multilatéralisme est derrière tout l'
architecture des droits de l'homme et de
la démocratie donc biden a promis de
tenir un grand sommet international sur
la démocratie
on va voir ce que ce que ça va être ça
ressemble un peu je trouve au forum pour
la paix que la kenyane macron a lancé
mme enfin sur un autre thème mais à peu
près proches et sur les droits de
l'homme
alors là c'est un petit peu une surprise
enfin moi j'étais un petit peu surprise
par l'agressivité et la fermeté du
président bailly donne
j'ai pas surpris sur le fond si vous
voulez mais j'ai été surprise sur sa
méthode dans les propos qu'il a tenus
sur vladimir poutine un journaliste et
il ya une dizaine de jours le
journaliste lui demander si ils
pensaient que poutine était un tueur il
a répondu oui je le pense qu'ils étaient
vraiment de la part d'un président en
exercice quelque chose de très très peu
diplomatique d'ailleurs l'ambassadeur
russe à washington a été rappelé à
moscou pour consultation enfin bon donc
c'était un petit peu fort
et puis vis-à-vis de la chine on a eu
cette rencontre là aussi la semaine
dernière où il ya quinze jours entre son
secrétaire d'état aux tony blinken
et le conseiller pour la sécurité
nationale james olivan avec des
homologues chinois une rencontre qui
s'est tenue en alaska à anchorage
c'était une histoire de l'histoire
d'être à mi distance des deux capitales
et vous les échanges publics parce qu'il
ya une sorte de conférence de presse
publique au départ ont été extrêmement
durs extrêmement violent est vraiment
sur le haut sur le coeur du sujet c'est
à dire les deux américains disant avec
nous la démocratie est de retour et
vous allez voir le modèle l'amérique en
tant que modèle de démocratie revenir et
les deux les deux responsables chinois
répondant vous n'avez pas de leçons à
nous donner notre modèle de démocratie
et notre modèle de droits de l'homme à
la chinoise tels que l'expression est
consacré sont tout aussi légitime que
votre modèle à vous et c'est pas avec ce
qui s'est passé au capitole le 6 janvier
vous allez venir nous donner des leçons
ce qui était effectivement difficilement
réfutable si vous voulez mais tout le
projet de l'administration by donne est
de réinstaller ce modèle américain ça va
prendre un petit peu de temps et de
rompre avec ce qui s'est passé comme une
sorte de parenthèse à laquelle les états
unis ne reviendront jamais bon
évidemment il faut s et c'est une vision
volontariste et optimiste
et donc voilà donc ça c'est le premier
point
j'ai déjà parlé des équipes je vous
renvoie donc à l'article de célia blanc
donc ça c'est tout si vous voulez ce
qu'il peut aller dans le sens d'un d'une
administration qui renoue avec la
pratique traditionnelle mais évidemment
on ne s'arrête pas là il ya aussi des
ruptures
enfin il ya ça c'est ma deuxième partie
comme vous l'avez compris il ya aussi ce
que j'appellerais dé continuité avec
trump est sous-entendu des ruptures avec
ce que faisait obama auparavant et et là
dessus le point de départ est très
simple c'est tout simplement de dire que
les élites américaines ont compris qu'il
fallait s'occuper des classes moyennes
et quand je parle des classes moyennes
je parle des classes moyennes peu ou pas
diplômés on pourrait dire classe
ouvrière aussi enfin les sociologues en
poids différents terme c'est à dire
cette partie la population américaine
qui a énormément souffert du
le système économique mis en place à
partir des années 80 la révolution
conservatrice de reggane et qui à
désengager l'état supprimé beaucoup de
programme de redistribution prétendu que
d'une part les individus devaient tous
être des individus isolés d'un point de
vue économique et que et que la société
prospère ray par le ruissellement vous
souvenez de cette la théorie du
ruissellement qui avait été mise en
place sous reagan dans les années 80 et
bien ce qu'on a vu c'est que au
contraire d'une prospérité généralisée
il ya eu une élite qui s'est enrichie et
une et une classe moyenne qui s'est
réduite en glissant vers le bas si
voulez il ya eu un décrochage social
le chiffre a cité c'est celui de l'
indice de gini qui mesure les inégalités
et bien cet indice il était revenu en
2007 2008 c'est à dire la zai de la
crise financière au même niveau qu'en
c'est à dire que comme c'est comme si
enfin c'est pas comme si il ya des
cycles dans la vie politique économique
sociale américaine entre eux plus
d'égalité moins d'égalité et bien là à
partir de 2008
à partir des années 80 et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui on était reparti dans le
sens d'une croissance des inégalités et
cette crise de 2008 j'en parle parce que
elle a été comme un révélateur pour
l'opinion publique américaine qui tout à
coup il s'est saisi de cette réalité est
bon on parle de politique étrangère dont
je l ai plus vite
en gros ça produit l'élection de trump
en 2016 jeu c'est un énorme raccourci
mais en gros c'est comme ça qu'on peut
interpréter les choses et donc si trump
s'est fait élire sur sept sur sept
réalisations il n'a pas vraiment tenu
les promesses qu'il avait faites à cette
classe moyenne puisque sa réforme
fiscale de décembre 2017 avec quelques
petits éléments pro classes moyennes mis
en avant soigneusement dans l'est dans
la presse mais en réalité elle bénéficié
aux grandes entreprises et aux individus
les plus riches du pays
c'est je pense avec l'adminisration
bailon qu'on va voir se mettre en place
enfin qu'on va voir s'ils se met en
place véritablement un état plus
redistributif et un retour en arrière de
ce balancier que je vous décrivais tout
à l'heure et ça ça concerne est alors le
point important c'est que ça concerne
aussi la politique étrangère puisque
cette administration dit qu'elle veut
conduire une politique étrangère
favorable avant tout à la classe moyenne
américaine ce qui semble un peu étrange
mais en réalité c'est parce qu'ils ne
veulent plus et s'abandonne l'a dit à
plusieurs reprises notamment pour suivre
les grands accords de libre-échange tels
qu'on les a connus dans les décennies
passées donc ça c'est le gros changement
le retour en arrière sur le libre
échange mais aussi une attitude plus
protectrice sur les questions de
technologie et notamment de technologies
numériques pas évidemment tout ceci se
dessine
face à la chine puisque aujourd'hui on
est maintenant dans une situation où si
vous les relations internationales
depuis des années sont en train de se
réorganiser le long d'un axe d'un duo
paul sino-américain et toutes les
questions de technologie de protection
du numérique se dessine dans ce dans ce
cette nouvelle architecture
internationale
un point important par exemple c'est que
vous souvenez que trump avait interdit
aux américains mais aussi aux alliés de
ceux de contracter avec l'entreprise
huawei pour se fournir en technologie 5g
et bien on a appris il ya quelques
semaines que l'administration by donne
poursuit cette interdiction à ce souhait
d'interdiction ce qu'ils n'ont pas
vraiment le pouvoir d'interdire à leurs
alliés de faire ce qu'ils veulent mais
ils ont poursuivi et même renforcer les
limites posées à l'entreprise chinoise
pour vendre en tout cas aux états unis
voilà je vais m'arrêter là donc oui on
donc en gros il ya quand même un
retourné il ya un retournement très
important de 2 comment dirais-je est-ce
que j'oserais le mot de philosophie
politique sur la politique étrangère
américaine et sur cette opposition à la
chine je conclurai en disant qu' elle
est aujourd'hui vraiment bipartisane
c'est l'un des rares thèmes absolument
bipartisans à washington cirque de tout
le spectre politique les chinois sont le
nouvel ennemi
alors quand on est démocrate on va
plutôt appuyé sur les droits de l'homme
mais à la gauche du parti démocrate
comme à droite on parle beaucoup de
tricheries commerciales et économiques
et financières venues de la chine donc
il ya vraiment tous azimuts et peut-être
pour être très optimiste je dirais qu'il
ya peut-être là pour cette société pour
cette ce système politique américain si
polarisé aujourd'hui presque hystérique
dans la polarisation un prétexte avec
cette opposition à la chine pour
peut-être dans les années qui viennent
retrouver une unité nationale cirque
comme de la même manière que démocrates
et républicains s'opposaient s'étaient
retrouvés dans leur opposition à l'urss
dans les années de guerre froide
peut-être que là on pourra voir mais
j'ai pas la réponse à certains il ya
c'est une hypothèse
tous les américains politique se réunir
dans une opposition nationale face à
l'ennemi chinois voilà merci beaucoup
merci madame heures dont monsieur seul
un oui donc bonjour à tous merci encore
pour cette invitation qui nie qui
m'honore alors en complément de ce que
vient de dire
laurence moi j'aimerais en quelques mots
vous parlez peut-être davantage de joe
biden lui-même parce que bien sûr en
tant que président mais vous allez le
voir en tant que joe biden il incarne et
il doit incarner la diplomatie
étasunienne pour les quatre prochaines
années et vous je vais essayer de vous
démontrer que cette notion d'incarnation
et de personnalisation est
particulièrement forte dans son cas je
commencerai par par souligner un fait
quantifiables en politique étrangère joe
biden bénéficie en ce début de mandat
d'une confiance très large de la
population étasunienne
selon le pew research center qui est un
grand centre d'études de l'opinion qui
fait des enquêtes à large échantillon
très fiable 60% de la population sondée
me fait confiance pour la gestion des
affaires internationales c'était par
comparaison c'était 46% pour trump au
même moment en début de mandat en 2010
est par contre c'était 74 pour 4 74%
pour obama on voit là sans doute la
trace d'une polarisation politique qui
s'accroît même en termes de d'affaires
international pourquoi cette confiance a
priori puisque comme laurence l'a
rappelé le mandat commence à peine parce
que
l'expertisé en matière d'affaires
internationales est un des grands atouts
peut-être prête même son principal atout
pour pour joe biden je voudrais rappeler
parce que peut-être ce n'est pas assez
souvent fait que on a affaire à un
président qui a passé 36 ans au sénat au
sénat étasunien puis huit ans de vice
présidence c'est en termes de présence
au congrès c'est le président dans toute
l'histoire qui a passé le plus de temps
au congrès avant sa présidence et il se
trouve que pendant pendant ces j'allais
dire 44 ans de mandat précédent
aussi bien au sénat qu'à la vice
présidence il a développé
particulièrement une appétence et une
très forte expertise en politique
internationale et en diplomatie il faut
rappeler qu'il a été membre
dès son arrivée au sénat de la très
puissante commission des affaires
étrangères du sénat on rappelle qu'aux
états unis
c'est cette commission en particulier
qui qui très comment dire reçoit reçoit
les traités internationaux et donne son
avis sur sur leur ratification et
propose son avis ensuite que qui voter
ou pas par par le sénat donc c'est une
commission extrêmement puissante il en a
été membre puis il l'a dirigé de juin
2001 à janvier 2003 puis de 2007 à 2009
et il faut rappeler que c'est parce que
c'était un expert en relations
internationales et en politique
internationale que joe biden a été
choisi comme vice-président par barack
obama
comme colistier donc à l'été 2008 puis
ont été élus c'est vraiment ça ressort
aujourd'hui de toutes les deux tous les
mémoires qu'on a pu écrire c'était
vraiment obama est allé vers lui parce
qu'il avait besoin de cette expertise en
politique internationale et deuxième
point en tant que vice-président ensuite
joe biden a disposé d'un staff d'une
équipe dédiée en ça on n'a pas trop
l'habitude en france mais en tant que
vice président il avait sa propre équipe
dédiée à la politique étrangère et la
sécurité nationale équipe qui l'a
accompagné donc de 2009 à 2017 et qu'on
retrouve aujourd'hui aux premières loges
2 de son équipe présidentielle
anthony blinken qui l'a désignée pour
être son secrétaire d'état
son ministre des affaires étrangères a
été son conseiller à la sécurité
nationale comme vice-président de 2009 à
par ailleurs moins connus mais aussi
très important colline call qui a été
son second conseiller à la sécurité
nationale comme vice président lui a été
désigné aujourd'hui qui est d'ailleurs
avait été le principal inspirateur ou un
des grands inspirateurs et négociateur
de l'accord nucléaire avec l'iran est
bien colline call devrait devenir et
entre il a été désigné aujourd'hui par
le président baden pourrait être
responsable de la planification
politique au pentagone au ministère de
la défense ce qui est un ski est un
poste extrêmement important donc non
seulement il est très expérimenté mais
joe biden comme vice comme président
s'appuie sur des équipes rodées sur des
gens qu'il connaît parfaitement et avec
lesquels il a l'habitude de travailler
c'est très important pour lui parce que
il a une conception de la diplomatie la
politique internationale et je voudrais
insister sur ce point qui est très
personnalisé très pour lui
la diplomatie l'a écrit la dit très
souvent c'est une relation d'homme à
homme donc ce qui implique de travailler
avec des hommes avec qui on est et où
des femmes avec qui on a une relation
extrêmement longues durable dans le
temps de confiance et aussi ensuite de
traiter énormément la relation
personnelle avec leurs homologues
l'homologue étrangers c'est ainsi que
joe biden s'était distingué au quand il
était vice président lors de son voyage
en chine en 2013
en emmenant sa petite fille donc voilà
toujours cette conception très familial
très personnel qui valorise l'humain et
qui lui est vraiment très propre à tel
point que xi jinping qui l'a connu à
l'époque où lui même au xi jinping
n'était pas encore numéro un et numéro
deux de la chine a salué son alors une
nuance d'ironie sans doute un petit peu
mais qu'il a salué son vieil ami
puisqu'il s'était connu tous les deux
quand ils n'étaient pas encore numéro un
et est donc il ya cette notion vraiment
de relations humaines de relations
personnelles
sur le fond il faut aussi regarder cette
expérience de bail donne comme
vice-président parce qu'elle nous
apprend beaucoup en politique étrangère
nous donne des pistes sur ce que
pourrait être sa présidence tout d'abord
rappelé que comme vice président il a
été l'homme du désengagement en irak
c'est le dossier que l'uac obama lui a
confié dès le premier jour de sa
présidence en 2009
et de fait l'irak et la gestion du
dossier irakien est essentiel pour
comprendre byden comme diplomate
et comme homme de politique
internationale alors on a et ça lui
colle un peu malheureusement aux bases
car une s'il peut me permettre une un
jugement définitif très sévère qui a été
porté sur joe biden par robert gates
ancien patron de la cia sous bush puis
ministre de la défense sous bush puis
obama et robert gates en 2014 dans ses
mémoires avec cette phrase extrêmement
sévère
il dit baye dingue c'est un homme
intègre mais je pense toujours qu'il a
eu tort sur presque tous les sujets
majeurs de diplomatie et de sécurité
internationale de ces quarante dernières
années
donc ce qui est d'une sévérité extrême
et qui tient beaucoup à la gestion du
dossier irakien
je rappelle que sur le dossier irakien
en 2009 2010 contre l'avis des
militaires des chefs militaires déployés
à l'époque au moyen-orient comme par
exemple mathis qui deviendra plus tard
le secrétaire à la défense de trump le
général mattis byden a soutenu avec ses
équipes à corps perdu nouri al maliki le
responsable chiite il a appuyé son
maintien comme premier ministre en 2010
et al maliki une fois confortée ensuite
le vrai pour hâter le départ des troupes
étasuniennes d'irak en 2011
c'est vraiment la bei den était vraiment
seuls à la manoeuvre entre 2009 et 2014
il a géré le dossier irakien lui même
s'était pas du tout obama n'intervenait
que très peu et donc quand obama a
retiré en octobre 2011
les quarante cinq mille soldats et
états unis en irak c'était un grand
succès politique pour by day à l'époque
il avait tenu un engagement majeur
d'obama en 2008
mais vous vous en souvenez sans doute la
gestion la gestion clanique secteur de
bab al maliki c'est la persécution des
sunnites en irak fut un des facteurs
majeurs de la montée en puissance de
l'état islamique en 2013 2014 et ce qui
est et ce qui apparaît c'est dans un
premier temps comme un grand succès
diplomatique de joe biden s'est retourné
contre lui ça a été beaucoup évoqué un
durant la campagne électorale l'an
dernier cependant ce qu'on peut retenir
aussi de cette leçon c'est que quand les
états unis finalement en 2014 ont retiré
leur soutien à maliki et ont organisé la
coalition internationale contre l'état
islamique
à ce moment-là baden a su j'allais dire
reconnaître ses erreurs changer de pied
et a joué aussi un rôle moteur dans
l'organisation de la coalition contre
l'état islamique avec au soutien
j'allais dire de brut mcgurk qui était
le l'envoyé spécial d'obama pour la
coalition contre l'état islamique et que
l'on retrouve aujourd'hui dans
l'administration présidentielle by donne
encore une fois de plus un toujours ce
trait de maiden de toujours travailler
avec les mêmes personnes avec des gens
et qu'il a déjà travaillé en confiance
favorisant l'humain
mcgurk qui sera le coordinateur pour le
moyen-orient dans le nouveau conseil de
sécurité nationale et donc ce qui est
important aussi c'est de souligner que
contrairement à une légende un peu naze
qu'on entend ici et là et qui aussi
beaucoup soutenu par pas qui avait été
beaucoup soutenu par par donald trump en
la campagne byden n'est pas du tout
un va-t-en guerre systématiques un homme
partisan de l'intervention armée
au contraire ça c'est très important ce
que nous apprennent ces années de
vice-présidence consacré à la diplomatie
c'est que j'enlève ganis temps il s'est
toujours opposé au déploiement de
troupes supplémentaires contre l'avis du
pentagone et des militaires d'où
peut-être là là là là est née la
l'aigreur de robert gates que je citais
tout à l'heure en 2009
il plaide fin 2009 il a plaidé auprès
d'obama jusqu'au bout contre l'envoi de
30 mille hommes supplémentaires en
afghanistan
et j'aimerais vous faire une autre
citation c'est que en 2010 c'est
désormais connu grâce à divers livres
qui ont été publiés en 2010 il a une
conversation extrêmement agitées
extrêmement houleuse avec l'envoyé
spécial d'obama représentant spécial
holbrooke qui à qui il finit par lâcher
en parlant de l'afghanistan je ne
renvoie pas mon fils là bas puisque on
se souvient que son fils était était
having était militaire et avaient déjà
fait un plusieurs périodes en irak je ne
renvoie pas mon fils là bas risqué sa
vie pour les droits des femmes ce n'est
pas comme ça que ça marche
les soldats ne sont pas faits pour ça
cette phrase on a beaucoup glosé sur
cette phrase qui a été effectivement
prononcées et nous montre quoi sur joe
biden et bien et nous montre qui a des
traits caractéristiques d'une doctrine
biden qui n'existe pas encore en tant
que président mais qu'on a pu voir
émerger en tant que vice-président quant
à la diplomatie fondée sur l'instant
très instinctive avec toujours un la
l'évocation du fils par rapport au
déploiement des soldats et par rapport à
l'évaluation du déploiement des soldats
supplémentaires en afghanistan
donc toujours fonder sur les sentiments
personnels et surtout très adaptable et
souple pragmatique
ce qui frappe chez byden c'est que il ya
une forme de pragmatisme d'adaptation au
contexte
par exemple ça avait beaucoup surpris en
afghanistan il dit bon les droits des
femmes les droits de l'homme la lutte
contre les taliban ne justifie pas
forcément que les états unis envoient
encore des troupes armées pour pour pour
soutenir cela s'est même baden qui 17
ans auparavant avait blâmé
l'administration démocrate clinton parce
qu'elle ne faisait pas assez en bosnie
pour protéger pour protéger sarajevo
à l'époque il avait eu cette phrase
définitive nous avons tourné le dos à
notre conscience morale donc on voit que
byden ce qui frappe dans tout se passait
en affaires internationales
c'est l'adaptation la souplesse et le
pragmatisme et je finirai c'est que
pragmatique mais autour d'un fil
directeur qui est l'exceptionnalisme
étasunien qui a toujours été sa
conviction profonde
les etats-unis ont vocation à mener à
conduire le monde par la défense de leur
valeur inhérente qui sont la démocratie
la liberté
d'ailleurs puisque bon évidemment en
début de mandat donc on manque un petit
peu de deux d'éléments mais il ya
quelques semaines l'administration biden
a publié ses orientations stratégiques
provisoire de sécurité nationale et dans
ce document publié début mars 2021 byden
dit dans le temps sont ses mots
introductifs notre avantage le plus
fondamental c'est notre démocratie et
donc pourrait bien affirmations de la
valeur suprême de la démocratie si pour
lui un chiffre directeur même s'il peut
y avoir des adaptations des adaptations
aux configurations aux nouveautés
il insiste énormément là dessus aussi
dans ce document en dix ans le monde a
changé
on peut pas défendre nos valeurs de la
même manière qu'auparavant et je finirai
ça il faut bien le souligner en effet le
l'opinion publique états-unienne n'est
plus la même dans la même enquête
oui sauf que je citais en début on
s'aperçoit qu'aujourd'hui 49 % seulement
des sondés
estime que les états unis ont un rôle
moteur un rôle actif amené à conduire le
monde est au contraire 50 % disent non
non la priorité c'est nos emplois
l'intérieur développer des états unis à
l'intérieur donc aujourd'hui on a une
population étasunienne beaucoup plus
réticente à mener à conduire le monde
et justement peut-être que
l'adaptabilité de maiden sera très
importante
voilà merci messieurs seul un merci
madame nardon je vous propose sans plus
attendre de laisser la parole à nos
collègues qui l'ont sollicité en
commençant par isabelle raymond pas vers
oh oui merci madame j'ai écouté avec
mercredi dernier votre podcast new deal
vous savez qui concerne la cyberguerre
une nouvelle forme de conflit entre la
russie et les etats unis
la dernière cyberattaques cela ruine de
2020 a remis en cause la sécurité et
l'intégrité de nombreux sites
gouvernementaux et d'entreprises aux
etats-unis 1
les etats unis la russie et la chine
sont les acteurs bien sûr régulier de
ces attaques d'ordre sécuritaire
économique mais également politique
le président joe biden avait pris sur ce
sujet à la parole le 4 février 2021
précisément et avait déclaré qu'il
n'avait pas d'autre choix que de placer
les questions de cybersécurité au plus
haut niveau au sein de la maison blanche
avant de prévenir que les etats-unis
n'hésiteront pas à prendre des sanctions
envers la russie compte tenu du
comportement agressif du kremlin
et cela vaut aussi pour les cyber
attaques je souhaite connaître votre
point de vue sur ces sujets d'importance
majeure comme le piratage des données de
hautes sphères en direction des usa ou à
l'initiative est des usa est juste un
point sur la pratique du
multilatéralisme vers laquelle
reviennent les états unis ne pensez vous
pas que l'élection de baden
pose un risque pour l'autonomie
stratégique européenne qui consiste à
trouver un équilibre entre des objectifs
qui sont potentiellement contradictoires
aujourd'hui merci merci isabelle je vous
propose peut-être de prendre des
questions trois par trois comme ça ça
vous permet de vous partager les
réponses et je donne tout de suite sa
part l'un d'eux collègue gilbert roger
président nous le savons donc en 2018
d'une façon unilatérale
les etats unis se sont retirés du jc dc
pillot et si on le faire avec l'accent
un peu et désormais selon plusieurs
sources
il se pourrait que les états unis
veuille revenir à la table des
négociations ce que je trouve
personnellement toujours très
intéressant il vaut mieux parler que de
s'opposer mais bien évidemment la
condition du retour serait avec un
certain nombre de conditions sur les
taux d'enrichissement de l'uranium et
pour l'iran c'est les levée des
sanctions économiques immédiates donc
l'arrivée du nouveau président et de
l'administration by donne que vous avez
décrit les uns et des autres comment est
ce que on on peut sentir la façon dont
il aborderait cette question monsieur
vous l'avez évoqué donc ma question
serait aussi comment et quels marche de
manoeuvre aurait-il par rapport au
congrès mais aussi par rapport à israël
et à l'arabie saoudite qui dans ce
secteur n'a sont deux états assez
puissant et et vindicatif et puis tout
dernièrement puisque ça ait eu lieu
cette semaine
la chine vient de signer un accord pour
25 ans avec l'iran comment tout ça se
combinent
merci gilbert et enfin dernière question
de cette première série olivier cadic
tout d'abord le trump a donné l'image
des états unis des états unis comme un
pays qui se referme et on l'a vu dès le
démarrage de la crise qu vide avec un
travel ban très restrictif est ce que
l'arrivée de biden annoncent un
assouplissement pour permettre justement
aux citoyens de
voyager plus facilement concernant le
haut karabagh les principaux vainqueurs
supposé de ce conflit
l'azerbaïdjan la russie la turquie ont
semble-t-il profité d'un effacement des
états unis à la fin de l'ère preuve pour
s'imposer
est ce que le nouveau président
américain va plus s'impliquer que son
prédécesseur dans cette région est ce
que on peut envisager une renaissance du
groupe de minsk ce qui relancerait
évidemment la diplomatie française
concernant la chine puisque vous l'avez
évoqué à juste titre en disant qu'il ya
quand même une sorte de consensus qui
s'est créée ceci étant on pourrait
peut-être parler du côté économique et
comment le pouvoir politique abords de
wall street qui a des intérêts
importants en chine puisque c'est les
usines des états unis sont en chine est
ce que un plan est prévue pour rapatrier
justement des usines des états unis
puisque il suffit pas d'interdire de
travailler avec rouen oui si les autres
entreprises américaines feront produire
en chine on n'avance pas beaucoup
et vous avez évoqué justement cette
envie de reprendre le leadership est ce
qu'un plan multilatéral
quand alternatifs ou route de la soie ça
a été évoquée est vraiment en gestation
avec qui travaille t-il dessus voilà
c'est une question percée merci olivier
un homme nardon monsieur cela à votre
convenance
jacques michon recommencer on verra
après oui alors sur la cyberguerre
d'avant je vous remercie d'écouter ce
podcast et je signale à l'assemblée que
celui que j'ai enregistrée hier porte
sur la crise migratoire à la frontière
sud des états unis où je sais pas si on
en parlera si c'est de la politique
étrangère ou pas mais bon revenons au
thème du podcast de la semaine dernière
qui était la cyberguerre effectivement
il ya eu une énorme attaque avant
d'enfin qui a été rendu public mi
décembre qui l'attaquent solarwinds
menées par des cyber pirates russes et
qui en réalité se déroulait depuis le
mois de mars
c'est ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui et donc
des pirates informatiques russes sont
introduits dans ce jeudi rapidement pour
qu'on sache ce que ça veut dire c'est
que la firme solarwinds d'une compagnie
américaine qui propose des logiciels de
gestion d'entreprise ce a fait la paye
ça calcule tout un tas de trucs bon ils
ont proposé donc début 2020 au moins
si ce n'est pas fin 2019 une mise à jour
à leurs clients et dans cette mise à
jour est bien les cyber pirates russes
s'étaient introduits et avait mis dedans
des logiques des programmes malveillants
et donc tous les clients qui ont mis à
jour leur programme on fait rentrer dans
leur système des programmes malveillants
donc au moins à partir du mois de mars
ce cas est ce que ça veut dire c'est que
les pirates ont eu neuf mois puisque
c'était découvert fin décembre pour
espionner de l'intérieur ce qui se
passait dans les systèmes installés ce
qu'on appelle des portes dérobées des
backdoors pour pouvoir rentrer
facilement dans le futur et que quand on
parle des clients se sont énormément de
ministères américains les department of
energy department of difference j'ai la
liste l'avortement ont cessé absolument
impressionnant et donc il ya eu cette
attaque là il y en a eu une autre menée
par la chine contre microsoft qui a été
rendu public là il ya quelques semaines
bon voilà tout ça pour vous dépeindre un
tableau d'un véritable far west dans le
monde cyber
ne blanchit sont pas trop les états unis
parce que eux-mêmes font des attaques
cyber quand ils le veulent notamment
l'une des premières qu'ils avaient mené
contre les systèmes de centrales
nucléaires iraniennes les centrales
civiles de production d'électricité en
2009 il avait introduit un verre de
dents qui s'appelle qui s'appelait
stuxnet que ça et qui avait paralysé le
fonctionnement de ses centrales
iraniennes
bref ce que je veux dire par là dans
cette description rapide c'est que on
est un petit peu comme au début de l'ère
nucléaire si vous voulez ou ya tout à
coup une nouvelle vulnérabilité des
nouvelles armes qui sont apparues et le
système international n'a pas encore mis
en place de règles communes et c'est ce
qu'on a vu sur le nucléaire avec bon là
on était poussé par la l'immensité des
destructions possible donc il y avait
une sorte de peur qui faisait que la
communauté internationale a agi dans les
années 60-70 en mettant en place des ces
grands accords de contrôler les armes de
maîtrise des armements et bien
aujourd'hui on n'a pas encore fait ça
pour le cyber ça va être beaucoup plus
compliqué ce que les acteurs ne sont pas
tous étatiques que ça fonctionne comme
vous l'avez dit à la fois sur les
questions sécuritaires les
infrastructures mais aussi dans le champ
du politique avec par l'amp cambridge
analytica qui avait volé rappelez-vous
87 millions de profils facebook
américain pour pouvoir faire du ciblage
politique pendant la campagne de 2007
donc on est aussi dans le domaine de la
manipulation politique
bref ça va être beaucoup plus compliqué
le monde
la petite lueur d'espoir qu'on a c'est
que l'administration by donne justement
a décidé de mener un effort diplomatique
qui seront pas tout seul mais justement
une amérique multilatéraliste a décidé
de de pousser à la roue pour que la
communauté internationale se saisisse du
sujet et établissent des règles alors
les règles internationales on sait ce
que ça vaut mais au moins il ya une
règle qui est posée avec des sanctions
qui sont prévues aux sanctions
économiques qui sont prévus et donc ceux
qui ne s'y plient pas au moins ils les
règles sont sans clarisse ils pourront
être sanctionnés
et donc l'administration by dane a dit
qu'elle allait se lancer dans un effort
de 2 d'élaboration du droit
international sur ce point j'ai passé
trop de temps de temps là-dessus pardon
en ce qui concerne l'autonomie
stratégique européenne alors là oui il
ya vraiment les pessimistes les gens qui
sont très pessimistes dans la vie d'une
manière générale son chagrin de
l'élection de john dryden les enfin tout
cas les européens
les européistes parce qu'ils disent que
avec cette administration qui tout à
coup et croît à nouveau dans le projet
européen
les européens vont avoir moins - le goût
de se débrouiller tout seul quand trump
a été élu tout de suite après en 2017
rappelez-vous angela merkel avait dit
ben maintenant de l'admistration trump
et là vraiment nous européens il faut
qu'on se débrouille tout seul et de la
part d'une chancelière allemande c'était
une déclaration assez forte et bien
maintenant que nous n'avons plus cette
anti européen à washington mais au
contraire un pro européen
est-ce que cet élan ne va pas
s'essouffler c'est ça la question
bon moi je n'ai pas trop de lumière
là-dessus mais je pense que c'est
peut-être un peu se montrer trop
pessimiste que de penser ça mais je
m'arrête là commenta je te donne
je vais répondre aux questions sur sur
l'iran pour l'instant il ya une
difficulté de toute évidence pour
l'administration baden à rétablir le
ne serait-ce que des discussions avec
l'iran pour j'allais dire négocier un
retour
a amené du côté américain un retour dans
l'accord et du côté iranien
l'abandon de toutes les deux toutes les
entorses faites au respect des clauses
de l'accord depuis depuis le
rétablissement des sanctions étasunienne
et on a appris avant-hier que
l'administration byden justement pour
établir cette ce dialogue qui n'est pas
qui n'est pas entamée aurait fait passer
une nouvelle proposition proposant en
échange de l'allègement de certaines
sanctions étasunienne que l'iran
revienne sur certaines mesures qu'elle a
prises concernant fin certaine certains
travaux qu'elle a relancé sur les
centrifugeuses et l'enrichissement de
l'uranium
mais apparemment malgré cette
proposition etats unis n
la situation reste bloquée pour une
bonne et simple raison et le ministre
des affaires étrangères iranien l'a bien
résumé il ya quelques jours les iraniens
considèrent que ce ne sont pas eux qui
sont parties de l'accord ce ne sont pas
eux qui ont jamais dire en quelque sorte
violé l'accord
ce n'est pas donc à eux de faire le
premier pas et ils reviennent toujours à
dire c'est une décision politique des
états unis ce qui l'ont fait
politiquement c'est à dire en partant
unilatéralement un beau jour de mai 2018
ils peuvent ils peuvent immeuble refaire
dans l'autre sens
au delà de cela il ya aussi un contexte
qui ne se prêtent pas un contexte double
qui ne se prêtent pas pour l'instant à
des négociations extrêmement fructueuse
des négociations tout court entre les
deux parties premièrement c'est que il y
à l'élection présidentielle iranienne
qui est prévu pour juin prochain et la
campagne
la campagne bat son plein déjà et il est
plus que probable que le futur président
soit issu des rangs les plus
conservateurs en iran et par conséquent
il ya là une incertitude politique en
iran qui king nuit de toute évidence à à
des négociations efficaces
par ailleurs j'allais dire que comme
toute administration étasunienne qui qui
arrive est peut être encore plus
évidemment après cette période si
particulière qui a été administration
trump l'admistration byden gère les
urgences et la première urgence et on
l'a vu et on en reparlera sans doute
dans cette région c'est l'afghanistan
puisque je vous rappelle que les états
unis avaient par l'accord passé entre
administrations trump et les talibans
une un délai au 1er mai pour retirer
toutes les troupes étasuniennes
d'afghanistan et que au jour comment
dire la semaine dernière finalement joe
biden a annoncé alors pour des raisons
de logistique que les états unis ne
pourraient pas respecter cette ce délai
du 1er mai et que donc les troupes
étasuniennes allait rester en
afghanistan pour pour quelques temps et
aujourd'hui de manière très claire et on
l'a vu
dans les questions posées à la
conférence de presse dans les prises de
parole le dossier iranien
aussi n'est pas n'est pas au dessus de
la pile
c'est à dire laissez pas c'est pas la
priorité et en plus il ya ce contexte
très particulier intérieur en iran qui
sans doute fait obstacle aussi à la
reprise de pourparlers de pourparlers
officiels
eh bien oui sur la troisième question
peut-être oui la troisième question est
ce que le aucun engin alors moi non
alors moi non plus je ne vais pas par
contre ce que je voudrais dire c'est que
vous avez si on peut élargir un tout
petit peu donc je reviens aussi quand
même à cette question vous allez voir il
ya un lien
dans le cas de l'afghanistan il apparaît
très clairement pourquoi les états unis
ou de la deûle excuses logistique
invoquée par joe biden la semaine
dernière l'idée c'est d'arriver à un
traité de paix entre la présidence gagny
en afghanistan un président élu et les
talibans est d'aboutir à un accord de
paix
le raisonnement d'administration byden
et se dire tant que tant que nous avons
des troupes
nous pouvons peser sur un éventuel
traité de paix sauf que et c'est très
intéressant
de ce point de vue les états unis
aimeraient passer dans un cadre
multilatéral onusien et dans ce dossier
dans ce dossier afghan ce qui peut être
ce qui peut être très intéressant c'est
que la turquie a un rôle pour les états
unis essentiel à jouer deux pour pour
comment dire pour pour les pourparlers
pour les pourparlers de paix et donc ce
qui renvoie à la fin cette question j'ai
à dire qu'il ya une vraie question sur
la turquie et qui montre bien toutes les
contradictions qui qui attend de
l'administration baden
du point de vue de la démocratie de la
valeur démocratie située byden veut
remettre au premier rang on se souvient
qu'il a eu des mots extrêmement durs
contre le régime d'erdogan qu'il a eu
des mots extrêmement durs sur la nature
de ce régime sur la nature même de
erdogan
qui d'ailleurs on s'en souvient a mis
très longtemps à qui a mis un certain
temps à le reconnaître comme comme
président des états unis
mais en même temps et en particulier par
exemple sur le dossier afghan
les etats unis peuvent avoir besoin de
la turquie
et donc c'est là toute la contradiction
c'est que on revient à l'idée faire du
multilatéralisme
oui mais sur certains dossiers comme
l'afghanistan on va devoir faire du
multilatéralisme avec la russie avec la
chine avec la turquie qui sont pas qui
sont théoriquement désigné et on le voit
bien dans les premiers documents
administration by dell comme des comme
comme dans ce camp des autocraties qui
s'opposent au camp des démocraties que
veut incarner les états qui veulent
incarner saison et on voit bien que
c'est c'est éventuellement une impasse
et de ce point de vue là la turquie
justement représente un point aveugle de
cette nouvelle de cette nouvelle
administration bail devant sur la
réouverture de des frontières à l'issue
de la crise duco vide déjà d'une
certaine manière le président enfin non
pas d'une certaine heure le président
baydan se veut beaucoup plus strictes et
beaucoup plus ferme sur les mesures de
distanciation social le port du masque
etc
donc il va pas rouvrir les frontières
pour des raisons enfin s'il considère
que la situation de sanitaires ne le
permet pas il va pas avoir de
l'idéologie là-dessus autre que ce que
lui disent que écouter ce que lui disent
les scientifiques et de ce point de vue
là la campagne vaccinale aux états unis
est très en avance parce qu'ils ont
pratiqué un nationalisme des vaccins
extrêmement efficace donc une énorme
balmain pourcentage très très important
de la population est aujourd'hui jacques
signer donc
donc si ça avance les pompiers pourront
rouvrir avec deux caves et autres qui
sont que 1
elles rouvriront mais pas elle aura pas
d'aidé
pardon des limites en fonction des pays
où les gens veulent aller évidemment on
va pas les rouvrir pour aller dans les
pays très affecté donc il y aura
peut-être des limitations de ce point de
vue là est deuxième et deuxième
incertitude
ces variants qui dont on ne sait pas
enfin je ne suis pas l'épidémiologiste
moi personnellement mais on ne sait pas
très bien si les vaccins sont efficaces
contre les différents variant pour
l'instant donc cette crise n'est pas
encore combien je pense pas qu'on puisse
mettre un point final à cette crise et
je pense donc pour conclure là dessus
que maiden sera très prudent et très et
suivra l'avis des scientifiques
votre dernière question c'était sur la
chine et cette espèce de de
contradiction entre une opposition
vraiment qu'on sent presque viscéral à
la chine au projet politique chinois
actuels dans les grands cercles de
washington et en même temps les normes
l'immense imbrication économiques et
financières des deux pays
on est dans une situation qui est
totalement différente de l'opposition à
l'urss dans le pendant la guerre froide
puisque les deux pays à l'époque n'avait
aucun lien économique
là maintenant comment rompre avec la
chine alors que les bons du trésor sont
possédés alors plus en majorité en ce
moment c'est le japon enfin savary par
la chine et que les importations de
biens manufacturés viennent de chine que
des investissements entre entreprises
ont lieu entre les deux pays donc on
parle de découplage on en parle aussi en
france mais savez je pense qu'il ya déjà
des choses qui se font sur les quais les
sujets stratégiques y compris la santé
mais je suis pas suffisamment
je n'ai pas encore vu passer
suffisamment d'informations pour dire
comment ils vont faire et je crains que
ce ne soit pas possible d'aller très
loin
et sur la route de la soie alternative
là aussi ce sont des projets qui me
semble beaucoup moins avancé que les
projets chinois eux mêmes
ce projet de route de la soie ayant été
lancée fera en 2012 ayant pas mal
progressé depuis
je m'arrête là merci winch au sol à deux
choses
justement si on prend les projets
alternatifs contre la chine
quelque chose de très intéressant c'est
que les etats-unis ont annoncé donc dans
la sous le nom de quad toujours sous ce
signe des acronymes accrocheur donc le
tuer en fait mais pour le dialogue
quadri latérale de sécurité ce qui est
nettement moins un vendeur avec le japon
l'inde et l'australie
il ya eu une grande annonce fait que ces
quatre pays allait mettre en commun
leurs ressources pour fabriquer d'ici
fin 2022
un milliard de doses de vaccin en inde
avec des capitaux et des investissements
essentiellement japonais et états uniens
et c'était évidemment qu'on le voit une
alliance une alliance qu'ils répondent à
peu près à tous les critères là par
contre de la dub hayden c'est à dire qu'
au moins pour le japon pour le japon
l'inde et l'australie ont donc uni des
pays démocratiques qui mettent en commun
pour un projet particulier sans être
dans des bureaucraties ancien dans des
bureaucraties multilatéral ancien là sur
un projet particulier on met en commun
ces ressources est évidemment le but
c'est de contrer c'est pour ça que ça me
paraît relever d'autres questions c'est
contré la diplomatie du vaccin chinois
les chinois ont déjà promis d'offrir 500
millions de 12 de vaccin à divers pays
en particulier des pays des pays en
développement depuis mai 2000 20 est
bien là les états unis mais dans
l'alliance et dans une alliance de
démocratie contre en quelque sorte la
diplomatie vaccinale chinoise et on peut
le voir comme une forme de modèles de
prototype de ce que de ce qu'ils
pourront faire à l'avenir et je n'avais
pas fini de répondre à la question et je
m'en excuse sur le mais ça nous ramène
juste sur le sur le congrès sur le rôle
du congrès rappeler simplement la
situation donc quand on parle du congrès
ont pas au politique étrangère on ne
parle que du sénat qui détient en cette
matière le la haute main donc on
rappelle que on est dans une situation
un peu particulière puisqu'on est à
50/50 au sénat états unis en ce moment
ce qui donne une majorité technique qui
n'est pas une véritable majorité mais
une majorité technique aux démocrates
donc a priori pour pour joe biden ça
devrait vouloir dire avoir les mains
libres mais on se rend compte que ce
n'est pas du tout le cas
parce qu'évidemment s'adonnent à
l'intérieur de la majorité démocrate
un rôle décisif capital à des sénateurs
démocrates conservateurs en particulier
un d'entre eux qui est un sénateur de
virginie occidentale du nil occidental
qui est petit état qui a voté qui a voté
massivement pour trump en 2016 comme en
2020 qui même le choeur de et qui se
trouve avoir un sénateur démocrate john
mann chine et par exemple pour vous
donner un exemple
djoman chine donc la virginie
occidentale est un état charbonnier
lourdes jaillir lourdement charbonnier
qui est hostile à toute évolution trop
forte en matière de climat dans quelle
mesure un monde chine soutiendrait des
initiatives
des initiatives étasunienne dans des
alliances mondiales sur le climat qui
viendraient qui viendraient devant le
congrès c'est ça part et ça paraît très
très très doute donc une situation
certes qui a été rendue plus confortable
par les deux victoires en géorgie début
début janvier mais un sénat quand même
où les choses si on devait passer par le
sénat pour pour des lois des ratifier
les traités des lois et ses acquis
maiden doit quand même être vigilant
d'autant que le nouveau dit président le
nouveau patron de la commission des
affaires étrangères du sénat bodemann
and s tu as un sénateur d'origine
cubaine du new-jersey qu'abidal ne
connaît pas forcément très bien
puisqu'il est arrivé au sénat ben bon
ils ont ils ont servi deux ans ensemble
donc c'est pas c'est un des vieux des
derniers vieux camarade de bayonne
jackpot du sénat dont il ya pas cette
relation forcément personnel et par
ailleurs c'est quelqu'un qui est connu
pour avoir une personnalité très fort
très très développé et qui a déjà
annoncé qu'ils ne donneraient pas de
chèque en blanc administration by donne
tout démocrate qu'elle soit voile sur
les relations il ya plusieurs questions
sur les relations avec l'union
européenne je vais je vais dire quelques
mots puis je suis sûr que corentin aura
d'autres choses à dire
c'est évident qu'aujourd'hui l'union
européenne donc amitié et attitude
constructive vis-à-vis du projet
européen ça c'est évident en même temps
il ya deux choses à dire qu'ils sont que
1 lune l'europe ne compte pas vraiment
l'europe n'est pas un problème pour les
états unis aujourd'hui en tout cas
l'europe occidentale
évidemment a évidemment à la marche avec
la russie c'est un peu petit un petit
peu plus embêtant mais le cecil si le
dossier iranien n'est pas en haut de la
liste des priorités
pour joe biden alors l'europe est bien
en bas de la liste
et d'une certaine manière c'est une
bonne chose ça veut dire qu'il ya pas de
drame mais ça veut dire qu'ils n'ont pas
beaucoup s'occuper de nous et le
deuxième point en revanche c'est que
sur les disputes commerciales il faut
pas du tout s'attendre à des cadeaux de
la part des états unis de
l'administration bailon il aime bien les
européens ils vont être constructives et
vont être chaleureux il parle français
et ses jobs
blinken et compagnie mais ça veut pas
dire qu'ils vont nous faire des cadeaux
sur les nombreuses disputes commerciales
que nous avons en cours avec eux parce
que ils poursuivent leur intérêt
national et c'est bien normal et donc il
faut être prêt à continuer nous
européens à présenter un front commun
c'est le plus important notamment avec
l'allemagne vis-à-vis de leurs demandes
anthony blinken dont j'aime prononcer le
nom à dix c'était en septembre dernier
pendant la campagne que si jamais il
arrivait aux affaires et si jamais
recommencer à négocier quelque chose
avec l'union européenne
il faudrait que nous lâchions nous
européens disaient anthony blinken
il faudrait que nous lâchions sur nos
réglementations sur les produits
agroalimentaires parce que nos
réglementations européennes sont
beaucoup trop tatillonne et qu' ils
veulent pouvoir nous exporter leurs
produits sans respecter ces règles
donc il faut s'attendre à des choses
quand même assez a sévi ville de la part
de l'administration byden il faut être
prêt et c'est pas grave c'est comme ça
que ça se passe
et notamment aussi sur
l'extraterritorialité du droit je sais
plus qui a posé la question
l'extra territorialité du droit qui est
vraiment lié aux privilèges du dollar
etc dont on a vu des effets extrêmement
important sur nos entreprises dans les
années passent et je pense que la
lustration by donne alors sera peut-être
prête à en discuter mais ils vont pas
non plus abandonné cette arme absolument
massive dans leurs relations
internationales je m'arrête le jeu cela
sur sur l'épisode syrien et plus
largement sur le positionnement sur sur
les droits de l'homme
je crois que je vais citer aussi anthony
blinken
donc le nouveau secrétaire d'état est
quelque chose qui revient et qui est
très frappant surtout quand on connaît
les habitudes
j'allais dire de la technostructure de
diplomatie étasunienne c'est là c'est
l'humilité et la modestie affichée et
surtout l'idée nous nous sommes trompés
donc en l'occurrence camping kane était
conseiller sécurité nationale de bayonne
puis il était devenu il avait servi
obama il a reconnu à plusieurs reprises
qu'ils avaient eus qu'il y avait eu des
erreurs
mik en particulier dans le dossier
syrien mais qu'ils avaient fait du mieux
possible qu'il n'avait pas en
particulier sous-estimé la montée en
puissance de l'état islamique et qu'ils
avaient appris c'est un discours alors
évidemment qu'il faudra mais on n'est
que deux mois dans la présidence by dane
qu'il faudra valider par des actes mais
une attitude extrêmement et qui ressort
énormément dans les discours de blinken
de dire on a appris qu on est modeste et
donc ferme fermeté sur les principes
parce que ces principes ont été on
semblait en tout cas assez assez
démocrate bafouer les principes de
leadership d'hégémonie pardon excusez
moi démocratique étasuniennes ont semblé
bafoués ou menacé pendant pendant les
quatre ans de trump mais évidemment on
ne peut pas revenir il ya aussi cette il
insiste énormément là dessus dans les
dans le document d'orientation
stratégique que j'évoquais de début mars
le monde a changé on ne peut plus ils ne
peuvent plus recourir à ses rêves
2-2 wilsonisme beauté comme on disait
c'est à dire d'intervention militaire
pour imposer la démocratie
déjà parce que ils sont plus soutenues
par l'opinion étasunienne l'opinion
italienne ne veut plus entendre parler
de ça je voudrais juste est toujours
dans cette enquête que wilson a été
passionnant ont demandé aux sondés
qu'est ce qui était le plus important
deux classés du plus important au moins
importants dans les motifs de politique
étrangère le plus important c'était de
protéger les emplois des travailleurs
américains
le moins important le moins important
alors tout en bas de la liste en
seulement 20 % des sondés le le disais
c'est est de promouvoir et d'imposer la
démocratie dans le monde
donc je crois que il ya fermeté sur les
principes
on l'a vu par exemple avec la
publication du rapport de renseignement
déclassifiés sur l'assassinât du
journaliste khashoggi où on a quand même
dit à l'arabie saoudite et au prince au
prince mbs voilà ce que vous avez fait
bon mais il ya aussi la prise en compte
que la diplomatie la politique
internationale elle doit se faire en
fonction des attentes de l'opinion
intérieur et que les attentes d'opinion
intérieur restreignent les moyens pour
affirmer ses valeurs démocratiques
j'en viens ensuite à la hajj ou la gaffe
on pourrait effectivement faire puisque
je j'ai la chance de le suivre depuis
plusieurs années
si catalogue je crois qu'il faut
remettre ses propos dans le contexte
d'une interview où il est sollicité par
alors je dis bien c'est un exercice où
il est notoirement connu pour pour ne
pas être à l'aise du tout d'ailleurs on
le voit bien c'est vraiment pas sans son
exercice prix privilégiés d'ailleurs il
cherche plutôt à éviter on a bien vu
qu'il a fait sa première conférence de
presse qu après deux mois de présidence
donc le mot lui un petit peu
lui un petit peu suggéré par par
l'interview d'une part il faut toujours
regarder les paroles et les actes
dans le même temps les états unis ont
décidé de proroger pour cinq ans le
le traité nous new start sur la
limitation des armements avec la russie
bon on a quasiment en même temps donc
ils vont y aller
j'allais dire ya les mots qu'on lâche en
interview et ensuite il ya la réalité
qui est beaucoup plus nuancée d'autre
part il faut bien le dire la russie pose
un problème particulier particulier
parce qu'il a des implications en
politique intérieure
le mandat de trump et c'est peu de le
dire a été marquée par l'ingérence forte
dans l'élection présidentielle 2016 qui
a été attestée je parle juste
d'ingérence un bien sûr d'ingérence
russe dans la présidentielle 2016
étasunienne qui a été attestée par les
services de renseignement puis surtout
du point de vue démocratique par une
commission sénatoriale du renseignement
ou les pourtant les républicains a été
majoritaire et qui a reconnu l'ingérence
forte de la russie dans le processus
présidentiel
on se souvient de tout ce que ça pue de
tout ce que ça a pu engendrer en
politique intérieure et dans le statut
d' donald trump et il ya eu une sorte de
redite de deux répliques en 2020 - forte
puisque le renseignement et états uniens
vient de dire qu'il y avait eu ingérence
dans la présidence et 2020 de la russie
et aussi d'autres pays mais moins forte
beaucoup moins forte et beaucoup moins
étendu la part de la russie mais tout
cela a mis fait du dossier la relation à
la russie un dossier presque autant de
politique intérieure que de politique
extérieure et avec tout ce que ça
implique
dès que ces deux 2 justement de
peut-être dedans d'excès verbales et de
rhétorique et il y a dans cette dans ce
mot lâché par par dubaï deux présidents
un petit peu comme la la continuation de
l'opposition entre des démocrates dont
une partie des électeurs était convaincu
que l'ancien président trump et et c'est
l'expression à la solde de la russie est
un bail donne des électeurs républicains
qui est des dirigeants républicains qui
derrière l'ancien président dénonce une
obsession malsaine des démocrates pour
la russie est donc je pense que l'excès
langagier et dans la suite de cette
transformation de la question russe mais
du point de vue et je reviens à la
prorogation du traité de limitation des
contrôles des armes nucléaires on voit
bien qu'il ya par contre des
possibilités il ya eu un entretien
entre entre baden et footing il y a des
possibilités
j'allais dire de réalisation
diplomatique si on veut bien sortir de
ce2 ce2 ce champ miné intérieur et
dernière question il sur la dernière
question parce que mes laurence a dit
l'essentiel
moi je dirai simplement ce qui est ce
qui est très frappant quand on lit donc
le document d'orientation stratégique de
début mars provisoire c'est que l'union
européenne n'est quasiment jamais citée
moi c'est vraiment c'est une des
premières choses qui m'a frappé à la
lecture du document et on revient à
quelque chose qui était déjà
assez présents dans là c'est prégnant
dans l'administration obama
c'est que l'europe est quand même
envisagé sous le prisme autant est
d'abord et avant tout sous le prisme
autant l'union européenne n'est pas
n'est pas n'est pas cité n'est pas
énormément cité dans dans ce document
mais ce qui est ce qui est important
c'est que par contre les projets et je
voudrais insister là dessus puisque ça
répondra un peu à toutes les questions
dans les projets forts de joe biden et
dont tony blinken ya l'idée que le monde
est en train de connaître un conflit de
type nouveau
ce qui fait que peut-être que le
référentiel de la guerre froide n'est
pas n'est pas très adapté un conflit
nouveau marqué par une accélération
technologique que le monde n'a jamais
connu et que aujourd'hui la ligne de
clivage du monde sait ce que blinken a
dit d'abord en septembre 2001 et ça a
été repris la dent de documentation dans
les questions stratégiques
la ligne de fracture de maintenant et à
venir
c'est entre les techno démocratie et les
techno autoritarisme et que dans cette
lutte dont ingérence par exemple
électorale de la russie a pu être à un
premier exemple dans cette lutte ou
évidemment
le l'investissement massif de la chine
pour acquérir en particulier en matière
d'intelligence artificielle une avance
qui pourrait remettre en cause
l'hégémonie états-unienne passé et bien
dans cette lutte à venir les états unis
wii auront besoin de toutes les
démocraties qui partagent essais il
insiste énormément là dessus une même
conception norme est dominé par le droit
de l'usagé des nouvelles technologies
dans un cadre démocratique et 2 ce point
de vue là il ya peut-être la notion que
l'union européenne peut aider les états
unis à construire cette alliance des
techno démocratie contre la coalition en
particulier que la russie la chine des
de ce que appelle les techno
autoritarisme et de ce point de vue là
il ya peut-être un champ nouveau s'ouvre
à la coopération entre les états unis
l'union européenne parce que en termes
justement de réflexion éthique de
réflexion sur les normes de droit et
d'utilisation des nouvelles technologies
l'union européenne peuvent être un
partenaire très important pour les états
on étudie d'abord vous remercier pour
les analyses que vous avez fait les
relations transatlantiques retrouve une
certaine normalité à une élection de joe
biden mais pour moi aborderez les
relations et la turquie que l'élection
est l'arrivée des équipes bailon la
turquie semblait de plus en plus isolé
sur la scène diplomatique
les six jeux des sujets de discorde de
discorde entre la turquie et les états
unis sont nombreux l'a1 entre eux bien
entendu et la question kurde
d'ailleurs erdogan en février a accusé
les teams byetone des du côté des
terroristes
hilton pour sa part à la volonté de
défendre les valeurs démocratiques et
les droits les droits de l'homme avec en
projet un sommet pour la démocratie il
ya l'hippodrome a abordé les droits 30
août alors nature qui quant à elle vient
d'annoncer son retrait de la convention
d'istanbul qui avait été adoptée en 2000
cause
quelle analyse faites-vous sur le
développement des relations entre un
organe et les états unis
de maiden relations qu'il son capital au
sein de l'otan merci j'en viens
maintenant à la halle à la turquie sur
sur la turquie bon j'en ai déjà parlé
ce qui est assez intéressant c'est que
pour l'instant en joe biden fidèle à sa
salle et dire justement à sa
personnalisation la diplomatie pratiquer
une forme de il bat froid ailleurs de
fanny lille refuse de lui parler il ne
s'adresse pas à lui est ce qui a amené
on l'a noté ça a été très noter ces
derniers jours r doan a essayé de
multiplier un petit peu les signes de
bonne volonté pour pour pour entrer dans
les bonnes grâces étasunienne il ya
beaucoup de sujets de conflit par
exemple apparemment l'admistration
gardera n'aurait fait une offre puisque
on se se sur le fameux dossier du f35
l'avion l'avion étasunien que trump
avait exclu la turquie parce qu'elle
n'avait pas elle n'avait pas renoncé à
l'achat du système de défense russe s
400 donc perdre à la fédé a fait des
propositions à fait à fédérer pour
l'instant l'admistration byden ne répond
pas parce que joe biden
considère que
si erdogan et la turquie ont pu par
exemple en syrie avoir avoir tant de
marge de manoeuvre
c'est précisément parce que il considère
que son prédécesseur sur ce dossier
précis à l'essai à hélices et a laissé
la turquie d'erdogan faire absolument ce
qu'elle voulait et il conte il entend
j'allais dire
remettre la turquie
dans une relation plus hiérarchisé et
faire sentir à la turquie que face aux
états unis et doit elle doit
et doit complaire et écoutez donc en ce
moment il ya un peu une épreuve une
épreuve de force entre entre les deux
est justement dans les dents les signes
en signaux envoyés par ailleurs doan il
ya ces pourparlers de paix dans le lion
de conflit afghan qui seront tenues à
istanbul ces initiatives prises par la
turquie et qui apparaît là aussi un
petit peu pour rentrer dans les bonnes
grâces de la nouvelle administration
d'haydn mais pour l'instant ça ne marche
pas avec joe biden il est toujours aussi
remonté donc
donc voilà ce que je pouvais dire sur
sur le proche orient pour pour finir sur
sur la notion de deux doubles enfin et
revenir sur des choses qu'on revient un
petit peu sur deux sur des choses qu'on
a déjà dit comment c'est un peu tout le
problème c'est à dire que par rapport à
la russie et à la chine
il y a cette notion que et c'est là
encore que le paradigme de guerre froide
paraît pas en ce qui concerne la chine
c'est bien beau de dire voilà on
alliance des démocraties des techno
démocratie contre l'alliance des
autocraties etc
mais en même temps on partage et c'est
particulièrement vrai avec la chine
le même le même capitalisme et la même
forme de capitalisme est il ya une
interdépendance économique qui
n'existait pas du tout à l'époque de la
guerre froide et toutous le tout
problème c'est comment faire fonctionner
le monde avec une telle opposition sur
des principes politiques et qui est réel
et en même temps une interdépendance
économique totale et je reviens une des
premières questions c'est que il ya eu
une tentative
qui était exprimé aussi parlé parlé par
la guerre des tarifs douaniers avec avec
la chine il ya une tentation pas une
tentative une tentation de 2d sinisation
d'économie étasunienne soussou trump
alors certes le flux de les flux de
vidéos d'investissements directs
étrangers ont baissé depuis 2010 est de
l'aide des etats unis vers la chine
avant même la crise du coc vide et mais
on voit bien que c'est impossible il ya
une telle interdépendance ne serait ce
que par les les titres de dettes que
détiennent les investisseurs publics
chinois les investisseurs privés de tête
de dette étasunienne et est donc tout le
problème aujourd'hui c'est comment être
dans un dans un affrontement de valeur
qui est nécessaire pour rassembler du
côté étasunien face à des pays que je
peux être en détresse du point de vue
des idées mais que avec lesquels on
partage le même monde capitaliste et le
même capitalisme financier et ça c'est
vraiment une question compliquée je
crois que madame d'ardon souhaitait
compléter
oui parce qu'en fait on n'a pas j'avais
oublié de répondre sur la question de du
proche orient et plus précisément du
conflit israélo palestinien
donc on a su que ce outre ' fois le le
le les politiques américains sont très
pro israélien d'une manière générale
trucks ne l'était pas beaucoup avant de
faire de la politique mais il a appris l
lettres pendant qu'il était à la maison
blanche pour complaire surtout à la base
évangélique
vous savez de de son électorat
les évangéliques américaines sur ces
dénominations protestantes très fervente
son est très très très conservatrice est
très très républicaine sont très
sioniste et donc trump a tout fait pour
leur plaire et notamment le transfert de
l'ambassade des états unis de tel aviv à
jérusalem alors là dessus by donne lui
aussi et affiche évidemment un trait une
très grande amitié et un très grand
respect de l'alliance avec israël et
donc il a déjà dit qu'il ne reviendrait
pas sur le transfert de cette ambassade
si vous voulez le transfert de certains
passages qui était promis depuis des
années par les présidents américains je
vois que ça datait de bush père mais ça
n'avait jamais été cette promesse
n'avait jamais été actée trump l'a acté
et je pense que maintenant ce sera
impossible politiquement pour un
président américain de revenir en
arrière là dessus et de re des places et
ambassades donc ça ça va rester ce qui
n'empêche pas que joe biden donc très
pro-israélien à titre personnel soit un
peu gêné aux entournures sur cette
question parce que là on n'en a pas
encore parlé mais il ya un grand enfin
une certaine césure au sein du parti
démocrate entre le courant centriste qui
est le sien et la gauche du parti donc
représenté par bernie sanders un petit
peu moins elizabeth warren ou sept élus
alexandria occasio cortese représentante
de new york qui sont très à gauche dans
le contexte américain et bien eu en
matière de politique étrangère
il ne met pas en avant comment dirais-je
il met en avant un rôle morale de
l'amérique ça c'est évident peut-être
moins interventionniste mais pour eux ce
rôle morale de l'amérique donc pour la
gauche du parti démocrate
elle ne doit pas être fondée sur le
principe elle ne doit pas mettre en haut
de la liste si vous voulez le principe
de liberté de liberté politique de
défense des droits de l'homme de défense
de la démocratie
ça c'est la vision du courant byden du
globe dont je parlais tout à l'heure ça
pour eux la la moralité de l'amérique
dans le monde sait défendre la liberté
politique la démocratie etc pour le
courant de gauche du parti démocrate
c'est le principe d'égalité qui doit
être mis en avant et le principe
d'égalité économique notamment
et et c'est très intéressant de voir
comment cette opposition cette tension
entre liberté égalité donc des biens ça
en france aussi comment cette tension
entre ces deux principes comme principe
directeur de la politique étrangère se
décline sur les différents dossiers dans
le monde
j'ai écrit un article dans politique
étrangère l'été dernier
là dessus nous où je passe en revue tous
les jeux vous y renvoie ce qu'on va pas
y passer des heures mais tout simplement
sur la question palestinienne
il est évident que pour un courant pour
un membre du courant centriste du parti
démocrate comme maiden on va mettre en
avant israël unique démocratie dans la
région
et donc on doit on doit défendre à ce
titre alors que pour un bernie sanders
par exemple on doit défendre la cause
palestinienne parce que ce sont les
opprimés de la région dans un dans pris
au piège d'un système économique qui les
étrangle etc
voyez donc donc c'est là dessus que ça
se joue et je pense que byden va être
très prudent et je pense très silencieux
surtout sur cette question merci madame
nardon bien mes chers collègues il nous
reste deux questions en visio je donne
tout de suite la parole
un autre collègue robert del picchia et
je demande à andré gattolin de bien
vouloir se préparer robert
on part aubert
robert est ce que tu nous entends voilà
ça y est nous tant qu'elle est en fait
tu mens tu attends président madaef
bonjour mes chers collègues bonjour une
question relativement simple à
comprendre mais plus difficile à
expliquer dans le résultat
bon on sait à peu près ce que pense mme
hayden pour hong kong et droits de
l'homme la démocratie etc
quid de ce qui risquerait de se passer
éventuellement pour taiwan
comment on pourrait envisager une
réaction américaine
merci merci robert andré gattolin oui
merci monsieur le président passionnant
débat moi j'aurais peut-être simplement
une remarque et d'interrogations auprès
de nos deux spécialistes
c est ce qu on a pas de tendance on aura
en france en particulier assure
déterminer les choix de politique
étrangère à l'aune du président
américain élu
moi je travaille depuis pas mal d'années
avait collé comme la semaine américains
qu'ils soient démocrates ou républicains
je participe pas nombreux au webinaire
c'est d'ailleurs passionnant de voir
combien tant du côté droit thing ou du
côté gauche avec mark warner on est
sollicité toutes les semaines sur les
questions stratégiques
la chine bien sûr mais les questions
technologiques et j'ai souvenir d'un
nain de ces faucons de l'air trump qui
était dans à l'époque le kram pt au
pouvoir qui me disait qu'il n'avait
aucune confiance sur la fermeté des
positions de donald trump à l'égard de
la chine parce qu'il me disait si le
gouvernement chinois pouvait promettre à
donald trump qu'il assurerait sa
réélection il serait prochinois en
revanche ce qui est notable c'est ce
caractère bi partisan sur la question de
la chine pendant longtemps on avait des
démocrates qui se focalisaient notamment
autour de nancy pelosi sur la question
des droits de l'homme et des
républicains uniquement sur les
questions de compétition économique
aujourd'hui on regarde des échanges et
des informations que je peux avoir
je sens qu'il ya une très forte
convergence et pour insister sur ce rôle
du congrès dans la détermination de la
politique extérieure
je me rappelle quand
deuxième partie de 2010 neuf filets été
adopté human rights and democracy actes
hong kong
très clairement dans un premier temps
voté au sénat à l'unanimité et à
l'unanimité moins une voix à la chambre
des représentants le président trump
refusé de le signer et des eu un retour
des chambres en dix ans on a le droit
d'outrepasser la signature du président
si on revote à l'unanimité et là donald
trump qui n'était pas très chaud s'est
exécuté pas moi j'aimerais que vous nous
disiez un petit peu si cette évolution
est ce rapprochement ces convergences de
plus en plus grande entre les deux
grands camps politiques au sein du
congrès à mon avis son team pas plus
déterminant sur les orientations des
présidents que les choix ou les
convictions propres des uns et des
autres je vous remercie
merci andré ménard dont monsieur seul 1
5 minutes pour pour conclure et répondre
à ces deux questions
donc alors je réponds déjà la question
sur sur taïwan je crois que dubaï donne
à envoyer un signal extrêmement fort
dont naples est passé par les faut
savoir que pour la première fois depuis
la reconnaissance de la chine populaire
et la rupture des relations avec taiwan
depuis la fin des années soixante dix
l'envoyé l'envoyé spécial de taiwan a
été invité à l'investiture de joe biden
et a assisté à l'investiture de joe
biden et je crois qu'il faut vraiment
prendre ce geste alors qui peut paraître
éminemment symbolique mais qui est qui
très fort comme une ligne jaune rouge
sur la couleur vous préférez qui a été
tracé par joe biden surtout au regard
des événements de hong kong
à propos de taïwan
il n'y aura aucune aucune concession sur
sur taïwan et de ce point de vue
d'ailleurs il n'ya pas deux il n'y a pas
de rupture a vraiment parlé
ces conducteurs la continuité avec
donald trump qui lui aussi avait
réaffirmé très très fortement
l'engagement l'engagement des états unis
pour la sécurité de taiwan est vraiment
par cette invitation à son investiture à
l'envoyé de taiwan vraiment joe biden a
marqué à marquer son engagement
je reviens pas par ailleurs ce sont ces
un autre dossier mais il ya aussi une
continuité un vraiment surtout le
dossier droits de l'homme vis-à-vis de
la chine puisque on sait que la miss
trash mobs hayden a maintenu la
qualification de génocide par rapport
aux 8 bourg en chine donc par ailleurs
donc sur sur la situation au congrès sur
cette notion de convergence et de
rapprochement je mettrai je voudrais
insister sur un point c'est que et
l'acquitté un peu les démocrates pour
les républicains sachant qu'on est dans
un sénat à 50/50 et qui peut y avoir des
événements on en voit chaque mandature
il peut y avoir une démission un décès
inattendu etc qui pourrait renverser un
set cette majorité en plus avec ce
système aux états unis que dans la
plupart des états se sont les
gouverneurs qui nomme les sénateurs
intérimaires dont on peut avoir vraiment
des changements très rapides avec une
majorité à 50 50 je voudrais dire que du
point de vue des républicains il ya
quand même une mutation profonde qui est
en train de se produire à l'intérieur du
parti républicain au delà de la
personnalité trump de ses excès et ses
on le parti dit républicain est en train
de muter sur une vers une ligne comme ça
demanderait beaucoup plus de détails
mais n'a su enfin national-populiste
identitaire
et autrefois le parti républicain en
matière de politique étrangère a été
dominée depuis l'époque reagan jusqu'à
l'époque bush junior parle par un
néoconservatisme dont on a vu les effets
au moment de dirac
on n'est plus du tout dans ce dans ce
contexte et on voit arriver de jeunes
élus républicains là nombreux à le
caucus république à la conscience
républicaine pendant au sénat a été
profondément renouvelée qui en politique
étrangère ont des positions assez assez
surprenante et trancher premièrement
alors toujours le refus maintenant
contrairement aux néo conservatisme
traditionnel le refus de plus en plus
prononcées d'intervention militaire
lointaine est longue
le un sentiment vis-à-vis de la russie
qui est beaucoup moins
négatif est beaucoup moins opposées par
contre et c'est là alors là pour aller
sur le terrain convergence et après je
laisserai la parole alors ans pour
conclure sur le terrain convergence au
congrès il ya une fenêtre pour
l'administration des douanes je pense
pour faire du consensus pour fabriquer
du consensus et de la convergence
c'est la chine précisément et c'est
peut-être pour ça que ça prend une telle
importance
la seule un des seuls domaines où on
voit une convergence c'est l'hostilité à
la chine qui reste forte chez les
républicains mais la mutation que
j'indiquais aussi bien chez les anciens
élus de tradition néoconservatrice mitt
romney et les nouveaux élus trump heist
il ya quand même une convergence c'est
l'hostilité à la chine au tilt et qui
n'a pas les même peut-être les mêmes les
mêmes racines elle est beaucoup plus
économique social est fondé sur les
droits de l'homme du côté démocrate
et on retrouve un anticommunisme qui a
repris une vigueur très très singulière
de chez les républicains pendant l'ère
trump mais ça peut être de ce point de
vue là à mon avis le champ de
convergence au sénat pour
l'administration maiden qui dont
l'hostilité à la chine trouvera peut
trouver un soutien bipartisans qu'elle
aura du mal à trouver ailleurs
voilà
d'accord avec ce que vient de dire
corentin je pense que la chine est en
effet mais on l'a dit pendant toute la
séance l'un des points sur lesquels les
états unis peuvent refaire nation en
tout cas les élus américains un poids
sur hong kong et taiwan donc oui
continuité même si sur hong kong les
états unis sont contents de laisser la
grande bretagne au premier plan sur
taïwan ya une grande fermeté affichée
pour l'instant avec un risque d'
escalade le moment venu face je pense
que la situation est quand même assez
risqué autour du problème de taiwan et
juste pour dire à quel point nous ça
juste pour que nous réfléchissions la
manière dont on voit les choses jeu j'ai
bien noté
quentin tu l'as dit le l'invitation de
l'envoyé spécial de taiwan à
l'investiture de joe biden mais
rappelons nous il ya quatre ans il y
avait déjà eu un micro scandale parmi
les millions de scandales quotidien
pluriquotidiens de l'administration
trump rappelez-vous qu'il avait
téléphoné à la gouverneure de taiwan que
je dise pas de bêtises mais il avait
téléphoné avant de téléphoner à chez
jean ping donc premier coup de fil
officiel à mes souvenirs sont un peu
floues mais à la la représentante
officielle alarme pardon à la présidente
de taiwan vous souvenez de ça et elle et
pas ailleurs
mais tout ça pour dire que je suis tout
à fait d'accord pour dire que
l'invitation de l'envoyé spécial est un
signe de la manière dont l'adminstration
valdan prend les choses au sérieux et
sait mais il ya quatre ans on avait crié
à l'erreur de donald trump et parce
qu'on pense que c'était une erreur que
son staff lui avait pas dit qu'il
fallait téléphoné à shenzhen ping
d'abord hees avait fait un scandale mais
voilà c'était juste pour une petite mise
en perspective l'administration
américaine a renoué avec sa diplomatie
ce sont les mots forts de laurence
nardon de l'institut français des
relations internationales qui a fait
part malgré tout de sa grande surprise
concernant le ton agressif employés par
le président américain à l'encontre de
vladimir poutine qui l'a qualifié de
tueur pour les experts interrogés par
les sénateurs la politique étrangère des
états unis
comme on l'avait toujours connu avant la
parenthèse donald trump est donc de
retour mais elle est à nuancer et
analysés
au cas par cas en fonction des pays
comme la chine ou encore la russie où
les relations bilatérales sont loin
d'être au beau fixe même avec joe biden
voilà merci de nous avoir suivi
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
se poursuit sur public sénat
[Musique]